Social Media soll unser Wohlbefinden
verschlechtern z.B weil manche Menschen
war die Image Probleme und
Selbstwertprobleme bekommen wenn sie
sich mit den durch designten Influenza
vergleichen aber ob Social Media
generell schlecht für uns ist dazu gibt
es keine eindeutige Antwort psychische
Probleme gehen oft mit Depressionen
einher Meta-Analysen zeigen aber nur
eine schwache Korrelation zwischen
Social Media Nutzung und Depressionen
eine Studie konnte aber zeigen dass es
auf die Art der Nutzung ankommt unter
den Nutzern die mit Inhalten und
Menschen interagieren waren Depressionen
sogar seltener aber unter passiven
Nutzern die stundenlang doomscrollen
waren Depressionen häufiger ob
doomscrewling depressiv macht oder
depressive Menschen eher gerne scrollen
das sagen uns diese Daten aber nicht in
unserem längeren Video zu dem Thema
gehen wir in die Tiefe und zeigen euch
auch warum so manche Behauptungen
totaler Bullshit ist an manchen ist
vielleicht aber auch was dran zum
Beispiel